>>> WEE T
WERNING.
ESRNOR GAVIN NEWSOM HIS STYMPTO
ENDEMIC APPR TCOR DEMOOVERNORS
REMOVE MASK MANDATES.
SOMEONE WAY AHTR COLORADO'MOCRAC
VEISTHE STATE' MASK MANDAT
HS.
ME W TO
SCU SO MUCH FOINING
UR EDID LIFT THAT MASK MANDATE
GH,
RE BACK,EVEN DURING THE NESURGE
R H  OSTY.
WHY DID YOU DOT LAST JULY
ARENATIC GOVERNO
>> KNOW, DANA,EALLY DATA.AT'SARL
TRIPLE VACCINATED HA 96% , DO
RA WAY, E ER TO VIEWERS F YOU'R
GET .
IT SACE GIN WITH.
KLE
VIRUS IS STILL SOMETHING YOU
RESPONSIBILITY.HOORARE DINGAYER
THEIR LIVES.>> DO U THINWE
REACHED THE ENDEC OFD-19?
>> I THINK WPORTANT
AN RTN
FUTURE.
I S ARING THAT
I HOPEHEAL GOVERNMENT AS
WELL.
WHAT DOE MEAN?
WE DON'T KNOWT
VAANT WILL OCCUR, WE DON'T
KNOW THE CURRENT RESISTANCE
HAVE BSE I  WEARS OFF.
WE NY INA ARTO
TO BABO ADMI
OF DOSES OF A FECCTH STOCKPILEPN
N WE WERE A YEARO.EED SURGE PRO
HOIT HEALTH
CAPA
ED AND AND
PREPARED OR RE BET
WORLD BE STRICKEN  ANOTHER
VARIANT OR RESURGE
COVID-19.
>>E CDCO
PREMATURELY.UCI IS WARNING G RES
I WANTWHAT
EK
>> WE'VE BEEN THIS SH
THAT INDICATES, YES, IU WATO RIN
MEDICAL-GRADE MA IN THA BUNCH O
GET9 BUT
OR FLU OA VARIETY OF OTHER IONS.
RE M RESPIRATORY CONDITION THEY
EYUIY
N TRIPLEVAXED,O E GER
M THE 4% CHANCE THAMETHINULTHEM
AMERICANPLPROTECT THEIR LOVED O
>> G I
THE POLITICS OF
WE'RE SEEING PARENTS PUSHINGBACE
VOTERS.
ATR ADVICE TO NATIONAL
DE T
>> TALKING ABOUT MASKS
Y TO RE YOUR N PERSONAL RISK,E
E TAG .
AS LONG ASREN THIS
MANTE VERSUS NO
MANDATE, THERE'S LOT OF
AMERICANS OF ALL PERSUASIONS
EGATIVELY,
RILY SO,G TOLD OR
TDO
TH ABO
HEARTS AND MINDS, ABOUT
PRACTICAEPAN TE TOOURSEL
HAE NINTH  DEATH
CAPITA
IT'ST
HA OE HIGHES
VACCINATION RATES PER CAPITA.
WE 9thTHS.ODATA TO
SOUTH DAKOTA ANDNOR N E  BEFORE
CHRISTIE NOMQ
RESIDENTS OF HER STATE.
CIRCULATING AROUND THA90% OF LG
ISEI D
WHY DOOU? I DON KSAE FIRST OPEN
AMERICWHTION TTHAT?
WHENPEOPLE, LGBTQ ARGETED BY THS
AND LAWSHAT SOMEOL
ESPOUSE, OF COURSE ICREASE.
MANY OF THEM ARE ALREADY DNGLLS
.
I THINWH IT'S AN
EXAMPLCAN OVN SU THE AMERICAN
LO PAST.
THE AMERICAN PAS A WHOLEAR AO
PEOPLE LOVW  LIVE
THEIR LIVES.S ABOUT SAYINGPLAY S
ANCEPEOPLE AREN'LOWE CERTAINCE E
MANDATING WHAT
THFRAN